pegi 18
[Musique]
voilà je roule ma mère voilà que je vois
mon père
voyez les voilà qu'ils m'appellent voyez
les voilà qu'ils m'appellent voyez les
voilà qu'ils m'appellent
cet arc est un peu grand pour toi non ma
mère me lafabrie pied elle a dit qu'ils
mettraient plus tard
[Musique]
on retrouve le tien
et
tu es fibres non existante sur le plus
haut pic des royaumes ses cendres
c'était son dernier voeux ou devons-nous
aller dans un royaume bien loin du tien
[Musique]
je suis le seul homme au monde à pouvoir
vous menez là où vous avez envie d'aller
on m'appelle nimy l'homme le plus
intelligent qui soir vous devez
commencer par me couper la tête 7 h 8
alors tu dois la manie avec grâce je
sais que tu es un dieu pas que ce
royaume je sais que j'ai raison
il ne sait rien paraît sur votre vraie
nature ou la sienne plus tu tardera plus
elle sera blessé il t'en voudra y tue
pourrait le perdre à tout jamais tu es
un dieu est lourd de conséquences
pourquoi d'amande douce est dans tout ça
la puissance de cette arme de toutes les
armes
viens ici mais ce mot si elle est
maîtrisée par sa part la discipline
la domination
tu as many cette porte
on a besoin de toi ce n'est pas une
maladie ordinaire
la vraie nature de ce garçon ta vraie
nature s'est pas enlevé
[Musique]
alors je suis un homme comme toi non
nous ne sommes pas des hommes nous
sommes plus tous à nos responsabilités
sont gigantesques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu peux tu as un truc aussi gros
faux